hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel since I keep talking about foot
picks I've also started considering
switching into ASMR now but seriously
today we're going to be talking about
load balancing so for those of you who
aren't familiar typically I recommend
balancing your load across many
different places some people decide to
be monogamous with their load but I
recommend spreading it out it makes life
a whole lot simpler anyways let's start
going ahead and talking about some
systems design okay so in order to start
talking about actual ual load balancing
what we must first do is talk about
horizontal versus vertical scaling I
can't remember if I've mentioned this so
far in this refactored series but uh in
case I haven't let's go over it quickly
so vertical scaling is pretty simple the
point is if we've got one node that is
particularly slow rather than make
things more complex by putting it over a
bunch of different systems let's just
get a more powerful node so I've got one
database congrats now I just put it on a
better CPU
maybe some more RAM anything like that
but of course that only works up into a
point and so massive tech companies
these days have instead preferred to use
commodity Hardware alongside horizontal
scaling and that's over here so we take
just one node and then we scale them out
with very similar different types of
other nodes in order to basically scale
them out and sometimes we might end up
having to partition if for example we're
hor horizontally scandling out a
database if we're just doing this for a
bunch of application servers which are
all doing the same thing that we don't
necessarily have to partition but keep
in mind that sometimes it is
necessary okay so now let's talk about
load balancers a little bit because in
reality this is not just a philosophy of
how to talk to girls but in reality it
is something that we use when
horizontally scaling so basically of
course when we've got a bunch of
different more or less identical nodes
that we can send our requests to we want
to make sure that none of them are
getting overloaded and that none of them
are getting getting starved from doing
any work and this is where our load
balancer comes in so it can actually sit
between pretty much any two layers of
our application as you can see right
here we've got a client we've got some
let's say app servers and we've got a
load balancer between them uh between
the app servers and our caching layer
we're going to need a load balancer
there because which cach are we actually
going to and then finally between our
caching layer and our actual databases
themselves we're also going to need one
more load balancer because again that
request can go to any of those databases
we want to do so intelligently and uh
the load balancer is ultimately going to
help us do that so let's talk about how
well the load balancer is going to
basically use a few different types of
routing policies in order to send our
requests to one of the different nodes
and so basically um you know because we
have multiple choices we need to know
where we can actually send them and so
there are a few different algorithms
that we can use here and I would say
depending on the situation that some are
better than others so for example we've
got round robin where basically if this
is our load balancer right here you know
we could send one to this database two
to this next one three to here and then
we would wrap around you know this is
request number four of course let's say
uh this node right here is 2x is
powerful then uh before you know we do
anything else we would send this guy
requests one and two and then we would
send this guy requests three and then
four and then this guy five and six so
that's kind of the concept of weighted
round robin there's also the idea of
lowest response time which is basically
just like you know keep track on the
load balancer of the response time of
every single node keep a running average
uh which does require actually keeping
some State on the load balancer and then
as we kind of get those aggregate
metrics whichever one has had the lowest
response time over the last and request
we can then go ahead and Route our
message over there ideally the goal then
would be that all of our nodes have an
equal response time coming back and then
the last concept that we'll talk about
and this is probably the one we'll be
using most in reality is hashing the
reasoning being that we can do smart
things with it and we'll talk about that
in a second so there are two types of
hashing that you can do when it comes to
load balancing based on the actual
message itself or based on just like
what is exposed at the networking layer
so that second option is called layer 4
uh you know it's basically load
balancing off of things that don't
actually require us to do like a full
read and decode of the message things
like the IP address the protocol and uh
that's just going to be faster because
again we don't really need to read the
message itself we're just looking at
headers and then similarly we've got
layer seven which in this case we're
actually reading the message content uh
that payload and that is going to be a
little bit slower but allows us to be
more flexible and sometimes we want to
be intelligently routing our messages
we'll talk about why in a second so the
next thing that we're going to talk
about is consistent hashing and so we've
spoken about consistent hashing plenty
in the past because basically what it
allows us to do is it allows us to
partition a bunch of you know keys and
make sure that when different nodes get
added to our cluster and they're taking
kind of part of that partition range
that the majority of the keys don't
actually switch their location so in the
context of load balancing let's go ahead
and think about what that's very useful
for in this case it's actually really
great when we have a local cache on each
potential place that we're load
balancing to so let me draw that out
quickly we've got our load balancer and
then we've got three possible servers
that we could be talking to s 1
S2
S3 right and so now let's imagine that
I'm coming in this is Jordan and I'm
making a request and the load balancer
sends me to S1 which is an application
server keep in mind and that's going to
route to the database which is then
going to return an answer now being that
S1 is a server it's now going to cash
the result of that Jordan call and so
it's very important then that if if I
were to go and reach out to the load
balancer a second time that I would go
and have my request routed back to
S1 because that way I'm more likely to
hit that cache data on the server and so
in this sense it is very very useful
when we are basically using a load
balancer to perform some type of hashing
and when we are performing some type of
hashing it is much better to use
consistent hashing then basically taking
the hash of my username and then doing
mod n where n is the number of
servers and the reason for this if you
recall is that as we add servers or as
we remove servers then n becomes either
n + one or n minus one and that actually
shifts the location of every single load
balancing result because uh now we just
have modulo a different number and so
instead what we do is consistent hashing
where if you recall we've got basically
a ring and this ring represents the
whole hash output range
and we randomly distribute all of our
servers somewhere along the ring so this
is server one this is server two this is
server three and basically the the the
requests or the hash range that go to
server one is represented by the entire
distance after server one and before
server two and so the reason this is
useful is let's say we wanted to add
server 4 over here now the only keys
that are actually being moved are going
to be the ones over here
which used to belong to server 3 but are
now belonging to server 4 so they go
from 3 to four but as you can see if we
were using the hash mod n formula and we
added a fourth server pretty much every
single other key would have to be
rehashed and that's why consistent
hashing is a lot better so it is
definitely an algorithm that we want to
be using when load
balancing okay the last kind of topic
for this video that I would like to talk
about today is going to be fault
tolerance so so far we've discussed load
balancers as if there's there's only a
single one at every single point between
two layers of our application and in
reality that's not going to be the case
otherwise we would have a single point
of failure so there are generally two
types of common approaches to dealing
with fault tolerance while load
balancing I will outline them both the
first is called active active load
balancing and the nice thing about this
is that because it is effectively us
having two active load
balancers we can achieve greater
throughput our load balancer won't be a
bottleneck for our application at least
it's less likely to do so at the same
time keep in mind that I've already
mentioned throughout the episode that
sometimes it is actually useful to keep
some State on your load balancer so for
example if you always want to like take
the request and do a routing policy
where it is like lowest average response
time the issue of having two of these
guys is that you know now the local
state is divided between two places we
probably don't have as great of a sense
of the actual response time again that's
not really a huge deal active active
does make a lot of sense but this does
lead us to the second possible
configuration which is an active passive
load balancer where you've got one guy
that's active the other guy that's
passive and when this guy goes down
they're both in communication with
zookeeper zookeeper is taking heartbeats
and then the passive load balancer will
eventually be able to read from
zookeeper that it thinks the active one
is down and then it in turn can take
over and start routing requests to all
of these guys the client can be doing
the
same okay so let's quickly conclude this
video because I am getting tired and
want to go to bed basically load
balancers essentially in any horizontal
scaling type of situation are completely
essential um you know this can happen
with your app servers your caches your
databases and at the end of the day uh
kind of the one main process to think
about here is actually how you want to
be routing your request of course using
something like round robin while basic
often still does get the job done
however if it's situation where caching
is involved and you want to be sure that
the same requests are getting routed to
the same servers every single time to
maximize your cash hits then something
like consistent hashing on a layer four
or a layer seven level of data is
probably the way to go for you anyways
guys hope you enjoyed this video and
I'll see you in the next one